well Congressman Jim Jordan he joins us
now to react uh Congressman I had the
pleasure of serving with you in the in
the Congress uh look there's malpractice
on this Commission on several fronts
right not allowing Republicans to choose
who's on their committee and everybody
knows that the person in charge of
security for the capital is ultimately
the Speaker of the House how can you not
investigate that component and call
yourself an investigation that's why
they would that's what Jason that's why
they didn't want to let us on the
committee in the first place because
they knew we would ask these questions
and get to the information we ultimately
got to really two things were going on
here remember there was that one message
that where that a reporter talked about
they were concerned about the Optics
well the reason they were concerned
about the Optics of having National
Guard presence here on January 6 is
because of what happened in the summer
of 2020 all the writing going on around
the country and the Democrats seem to
support it and call it peaceful protest
so you had that element and then you had
this pattern of approval that John
referenced where it was the speaker's
office the sergeant of arms office
working hand in glove all the time and
many of these meetings they didn't even
invite Republicans too so it was it was
a coordinated effort and then on that
day when it was obvious you need a
National Guard here the sergeant of arms
office had to go talk with the speaker
and obviously before they could take
action because of this this pattern of
approval that that had developed so that
was the real problem here and of course
not to mention just the overall
political nature of this committee for
the last year and a half their sole
Focus was to go after president Trump
um again a political committee I think
that the country sees it for what it is
uh Congressman I need to ask you about
what's happening over in the senate in
this Omnibus Bill I mean one of the only
tools that Republicans have come you
know January when they actually are are
are in control of the House of
Representatives is the power of the
purse and the ability to rank you know
build in the FBI and and and and reign
in the the Department of Justice and
demand some answers that you at
Judiciary and James Comer of an
oversight how are you going to be able
to do that if you don't have the
leverage or the power of the purse I do
not get why the Senate is moving ahead
with this I mean the Cavalry is coming
over the hill and January 3rd there'll
be a republican majority in the house
will be in a much better position to
deal with any spending any appropriation
Bill and and hold them accountable in
the things we need to think about you
mentioned the justice department they're
going from a 10.3 billion dollar budget
to an 11.3 billion dollar budget and
they're talking about a new headquarters
for them if that's even more than they
ask for by Nas for 10.8 and it's 11.3 in
this bill that's now in front of the
Senate why anyone would vote for this I
do not know know why any Republican
would vote for it in light of that
simple fact this department of justice
that was working hand in glove with
Twitter and big Tech to run an
information operation a misinformation
operation on We the People just weeks
before the 2020 presidential election
why would we give them a raise I have no
idea but that's what's in this bill and
a host of other bad things that I think
were best laid out in my colleague Dan
Bishop's Twitter feed uh just just the
other day where he talked about all the
stupid things we are spending taxpayer
money on money that that the families
that I represent in the fourth district
of Ohio getting their money spent on
some of the stupid things that are in
this bill so why any women support this
I have no idea I know you wouldn't when
you were in the in the in the Congress
you wouldn't vote for something this
crazy there's no way there's no way and
and why not wait the two weeks that it
takes in order to do this they do
continuing resolutions all the time but
I do believe when Nancy Pelosi was the
speaker when I was there back in
2009-2010 we did the same thing and if I
got the year wrong it was another year
where Nancy Pelosi she did this is a
tactic they wait till the end of
December when they think the country is
asleep and more concerned about
Christmas and then they pass it through
was supposed to be done on sept by
September 30th that's in the fiscal year
so if we can go two more months what's
wrong with a few more weeks for goodness
sake when we're going to have a majority
of Republicans in the House of
Representatives
uh I would be remiss I need to ask you
real quickly you've been referred to for
an Ethics violation supposedly I don't
know what it is do you care to comment
on that no I again I think it just shows
how political this this committee again
we've caught this committee Jason we've
caught him in several lines eight
different lies two of them about me
here's one that they did during one of
these big fancy committee hearings they
do with all their audio visual they
played a clip of me and doing the
interview and I said in the interview
January 6 is the ultimate date of
significance in a presidential contest
the part they left out was the first
sentence to that statement when I said
the late Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
said January 6 was the ultimate date of
significance in a presidential contest
because it is it's that final but when
you leave that off it changes the
meaning and they they presented that as
if I said it the way they put it on on
the film like that is how much this
committee is willing to lie all to get
after president Trump and the reason
they go after him so hard is because he
came to this town he did what he said he
was going to do he shook this place up
and accomplished things for the American
people for American families and that's
why they've been out to get him now for
seven years but the countries figured it
out they're not going to tolerate it
no I think that I think that's right
Congressman have a merry Christmas to
you and your wife and the rest of your
family uh thanks for joining us tonight
on Hannah do you really do appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else